on en parle évidemment cette campagne
d'entre deux tours elle est marquée par
la chasse aux
mélenchonistes et séduire emmanuel
macron et marine le pen ont adapté leur
stratégie un zoom signé un orbey reveint
genesta à quatre jours de la vérité des
urnes les candidats abattent leurs
dernières cartes sur la question
brûlante du climat le président-candidat
mouiller enfin sa chemise en pariant
gros sur la pièce maîtresse d'un
éventuel futur gouvernement mon prochain
premier ministre
sera directement chargé de la
planification écologique
pour assister ce super ministre emmanuel
macron en sortent deux autres de sa
manche l'un chargé de la planification
énergétique et leurs sacs de l'écologie
territoriales
aucune annonce de dernière minute en
revanche pour la candidate du
rassemblement national sur le climat
tout juste peut-elle encore rétropédaler
sur son objectif de démanteler le parc
éolien déjà implantés en france
l'êta démantelée
c'est ne plus aider l'installation et
attendre qu'elles finissent leur vie
parce qu'elles ont une durée du temps
dès qu'elles finissent leur dîner on
laisse démantelé pour ne pas les
remplacer on va pas aller les démons
recule aussi sur le thème de
l'immigration
le voile précisément dont l'interdiction
était essentiel pour l'extrême droite
interpellé sur cette question par une
femme portant un simple savait très bien
qu'il ya marine le pen infléchi
finalement sa position ce sont des
problèmes qui sont des problèmes
complexes jeu j'en suis parfaitement
consciente de cela je sais pas
comment dire obtus et et mais il faut
régler le problème des femmes qui sont
obligées de mettre le voile parce
qu'elles sont sous la pression des
islamistes ont plutôt qu'un recul un pas
de côté enfin pour le président candidat
sur sa réforme des retraites dont le cap
est fixé à 65 ans sans embardée avant
d'entendre que rien n'est finalement
passé
oui il y a une place à la négociation
oui il est nécessaire qu'il y ait une
progressivité ça ne va pas tomber comme
ça mais il faut absolument que nous
améliorions le sort des retraités et
mâcon à quelques heures du débat chacun
jouera lé 6 pour le ton la moindre
annonce très qu'à la moindre retouche au
programme dix finalistes encore compter
j'en ai pour séduire les derniers
indécis
le match macron le pen je vous propose 4
correspondant étranger pour l'arbitré à
navarro kedro ou bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes correspondante de la presse
portugaise à paris paul levy
correspondant bonsoir landes ça c'est
l'équivalent de la fp en italie richard
wehrli bonsoir d'un soir on a list
franco-suisse autant et vous publiez la
france contre elle même c'est publié aux
éditions grasset et puis on avec nous en
duplex philip earl qui est journaliste
britannique à
france24 bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre indice à invitation à navarro
pedro qu'est ce que vous retenez tient
de ses nuits jours de campagne d'entre
deux tours qu'est ce qui vous a marqué
au delà de tout ce qui est stratégie
politique de chaque candidat sécurité en
parlant avec les gens c'est vraiment un
énervement croissant à chez nous chez
les français chez les français
si on commence à parler de politique je
sais bien que vous ne faut jamais parler
politique des sociétés mais on soit en
énervement croissant un an choix pour
beaucoup une contrariété sur les deux
finalistes qui ne correspondent en rien
à leur souhait et puisque ne pas
correspondre à leurs souhaits ya une
hostilité vis-à-vis des deux et qui ne
savent pas quoi faire et qui ont peur
pour les cinq années à venir et quel que
soit l'élu mais au-delà de ça un
énervement qu'est ce qui va se passer
quels sont les choix
il ya un certain pessimisme aussi qui
tint les propos qui déteint sur les
propos des personnes contactées ça c'est
la chose qui me frappe le plus est je
les ai vus augmentons depuis le premier
tour jusqu'à maintenant
c'est peut-être ça se calmera d'ici
dimanche on verra bien que les choix
seront faits donc il y aura un
apaisement mais pour l'instant c'est ça
qui me frappe le plus au delà de toutes
les stratégies et au tous les petits
points politiques politique est
politique oui on parle et c'est un peu
la dissidence dont on parle et mathieu
il ya quelques il ya quelques minutes
par les villes présidentiel à la
française c'est quand même pour un
italien c'est toujours spectaculaire
parce qu'il ya ce système
verticales quoi absolument c'est
spectaculaire pour les européens c'est
un petit peu l'équivalent de la coupe du
monde de football en politique c'est à
dire que nous un à la verrerie chars on
vient tous de système parlementaire très
différents qui sont beaucoup plus
ennuyeux il ya beaucoup moins d'enjeux
ici en france ce système la vème
république rend vraiment ce débat entre
deux tours et ensuite le vote de
dimanche entre deux candidats quelque
chose de saisissant d'ailleurs ça
devrait entraîner des masses amant
rigolant avant de rentrer dans le dur on
disait justement dommage connais pas
bien mes gars écran au champ de mars
pourra suivre le débat comme pour un
match de foot où exactement parce que je
vous assure que c'est c'est
spectaculaire pour certains aspects
richard werly on a vu le reportage sur
les changements de pied pour ne pas dire
plus ce recul des deux candidats est ce
que vous les trouvez finalement logique
s'avère que c'est dans la logique d'une
campagne
présidentielle de la vème république au
premier tour ont réuni son camp et au
second tour on ratisse plus large voilà
très surprenant je suis pas très étonné
d'autant que la victoire appartient
finalement à ceux qui n'ont voté ni pour
l'un ni pour l'autre au premier tour
c'est ce et ceux du troisième homme
assez largement c'est quand même
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon qu'il
va faire cette victoire est dans le cas
de marine le pen il y à ce réservoir de
voix chéri c'est moi donc je ne suis pas
surpris et celui qui en la matière
affiche le plus un catalogue de mesures
destinées à ratisser large c'est quand
même emmanuel macron parce que moi
j'étais au meeting de marseille très
franchement leur qu'il a passée a
détaillé le catalogue écologie qui a pas
d'autres mots un catalogue écologique on
est on était quand même un peu tout
surpris on s'attendait à un meeting à la
ville avait démarré très anti le pen
front républicain et c'est bien ce qu'on
est parti dans un long catalogue
extrêmement précis vous souvenez sur les
éoliennes sur le ministre qui sera
chargé de la planification écologique
territoriale lui il est allé très loin
dans le détail et j'ai tendance à penser
c'est parce qu'il a une vision très
précise de l'électorat qu'il estime
avoir besoin de conquérir
et aussi plus sur ces bases parce que
c'est aussi un marqueur de
différenciation fort vise à une marine
le pen seulement mon pied a jeté il veut
lacornerie il me semble qu'elle est
quand même resté plus sur ses bases elle
sait moins éloigné de sa base dans cet
entre-deux-tours philip earl vous vous
couvrez je crois les campagnes
présidentielles françaises depuis 1988
celle ci qu'est ce qui ressort pour vous
qu'est ce qu'il vous semble atypique par
rapport aux autres ce qui est drôle
c'est que pour moi chaque fois que je
dois faire un reportage sur les
campagnes électorales en france on dit
tu le vaux au banc n'a jamais vu une
campagne comme comme celui ci à chaque
fois et je crois que on n'a jamais de
compagne comme comme celui qu'on vit
actuellement
pour des propos une raison précise que
pour le premier tour
emmanuel macron et ils pointent citéa
absent c'est marine le pen qui a
vraiment bien réussi sa compagne l'a
presque réussi à anéantir eric zemmour
j'avais du mal à comprendre pourquoi
emmanuel macron avait décidé de ne
presque pas faire campagne
mais vos montres est en mouvement ce qui
n'était pas une bonne décision selon moi
mais en même temps maintenant qu'on est
dans le deuxième partie de cette
élection je trouve que ces manuels
macron qui est dans une position de
force et c'est marine le pen qui
viennent moins bon compagnon pour le
deuxième taux pour le premier tour donc
on voit une espèce du changement de
situation alors que pour la première
partie de la compagne et manioc mâcon a
commencé bas et les montées au à cause
de laquelle on d'ukraine et toutes les
négociations économiques poutine et
l'âge
incarner ce chef d'état dont dans la vie
buzz moi un moment plein pour mener la
bataille est la france en pole position
contre vladimir poutine ensuite il a
baissé alors que marine le pen elle a
commencé faut l abc et puis il est
remonté derrière pour finir en deuxième
place et on voit un peu dans la deuxième
partie de cette élection le contraire
pendant ces deuxièmes tours donc c'est
vrai que chaque élection est différente
et cette fois ci on a encore une fois
une élection qui a appelé différente des
autres oui alors vous vous évoquez
philippe évidemment là l'actualité de la
guerre en ukraine mathieu vous vous
étonnez de la place prise par les
thématiques les questions
internationales dans cette campagne oui
moi je la réflexion en regardant la
conférence de presse la semaine dernière
de marine le pen sur la diplomatie
c'était du jamais vu entre les deux
tours j'ai pas le souvenir de candidat
qui ait fait une conférence sur grande
conférence de presse de cette façon là
sur les questions internationales dans
l'entre-deux tours
combien de fois n'at-on entendu que les
français n'étaient pas intéressés par
les questions internationales qui était
trop tôt centre est trop occupé à penser
à eux trop replié sur lui-même combien
de fois l'at on vu des candidats
travailler ou mettre en valeur leur
stature internationale souvent pour rien
françois hollande par exemple n'était
jamais allé en chine avant d'être élu sa
notoriété ne dépassait pas les limites
de la corrèze disait à l'époque les
partisans de nicolas sarkozy alors que
lui sarkozy tutoyait les grands de ce
monde avait en fait ça servira jamais
empêché de françois hollande d'être élu
parce que tout le monde s'en fiche et
mais en cette année patatras le retour
du tragique dans l'histoire comme le dit
elle-même macron a fait surgir les
questions internationales dans le débat
public un niveau qu'on n'avait jamais
connu comme quoi faut jamais désespérer
coup sur coup on a quand même eu la
pandémie mondiale de kovy des la flambée
des prix d'énergie qui a suivi ont remis
sur le devant de la scène est question
de souveraineté nationale et de
solidarité européenne on est la guerre
en ukraine c'est évidemment demi en à
l'accent sur les questions
géostratégiques d'alliance de défense ou
de coopération européenne sur le droit
d'asile notamment et puis même le débat
hystériser qu'on a connus sur
l'immigration à droite et à l'extrême
droite nécessité de reparler des
rapports nord-sud et notamment de nos
relations avec avec l'afrique alors si
on fait un peu le bilan quelques l1 pas
quel impact cette actualité ces débats
continuent sur la campagne la guerre en
ukraine a fait une victime en france
eric zemmour il faut le dire le
polémiste ne s'est jamais remis de sa
poutine ofili avancé al'inverse de
jean-luc mélenchon et dans un premier
temps de marine le pen jeudi dans un
premier temps parce qu'elle pourrait
bien faire une autre victime pour le
coup et ça serait la candidate du
rassemblement national qui a du mal à
convaincre à son passé pro poutine est
devenu un élément de langage récurrent
chez les maquereaux nist qui lui
rappelle son prêt obtenu auprès d'une
banque russe sa visite au kremlin ses
nombreuses visites en russie parce qu'il
ya eu que la visite au kremlin ces
déclarations alors les nos playlists
répondent en soulignant le fait que
macron avait accueilli poutine à
versailles brégançon bref voilà on est
dans un échange mais au delà de des
rapports avec vladimir poutine la guerre
du crâne a aussi conduit marine le pen a
précisé ses intentions sur l'otan sur
les alliances et là on a découvert que
malgré la guerre après la guerre il
fallait selon l associer l'otan et plus
étroitement à la russie aussi
redécouvert sa vision de l'europe d'une
certaine façon d'accord elle ne veut
plus sortir dans l'euro mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire quand on regarde
précisément les mesures qu'elle veut
prendre quelque chose a changé en fait
parce que le pays des gaulois
réfractaires des cours en fait tout
l'intérêt de ne pas être seul face aux
désordres du monde que la tentation du
repli sur soi souverainiste n'a plus
grand sens à l'échelle de la france mais
peut peut-être se penser à l'échelle
européenne
al'inverse si je prends le corps
d'emmanuel macro lui aussi il va devoir
répondre sur les questions
internationales son échec d'avoir réussi
à instiller pousser une défense
européenne ces initiatives diplomatiques
ont pas eu grand sens en tout cas grand
résultat à moscou voilà autant
d'éléments qui à mon avis devrait
figurer en grande partie sur la table du
débat pour la première fois dans un
débat d'entre deux tours présidentielle
et qui pourrait bien revenir à la figure
des candidats et notamment dans les
domaines comme un moment où on suivra ça
demain évidemment mathias aleviné est ce
que
il faisait partie matteo salvini par le
les vider
des poutines au fil absolument c'était
un peu la même démarche que marine le
pen notamment après l'annexion de la
crimée etc si je me souviens bien
exactement la même chose matteo salvini
et l un des pions principal de vladimir
poutine en europe occidentale dans un
grand pays de l'union européenne
d'ailleurs exactement comme marine le
pen matteo salvini a été reçu à moscou
il s'est affiché sur la place rouge en
face du kremlin avec un t-shirt à
l'effigié de poutine ça fait des
polémiques pas possible et aujourd'hui
ce même matteo salvini et soutient la
majorité
devait être premier ministre madiot de
la grille parce que comme vous l'avez
très justement rappelé on n'est pas en
train de vivre hélas une période normale
de notre histoire on est en train de
vivre des crises successives très très
grave est très profonde il ya notre
système de valeurs européen qui est
remis en cause et menacé chaque jour de
façon même pas du plus caché par la
chine et par la russie d'aujourd'hui un
seul impératif crucial c'est celui de
rester unis non seulement les chaînes
nationales mais à l'échelle européenne
parce que sinon on ne tiendra pas de
brouillard se fera en en cinq ans n'aura
que le châssis devenir des satellites de
la russie de la chine ou des états unis
donc même un populiste comme matteo
salvini très longuement a soutenu des
positions anti europe aujourd'hui s'est
mis derrière draghi et soutient lui
aussi ce principe de réalité donc ça
veut dire que depuis deux mois il a il
dénonce par ailleurs en italie à une
autre figure montante qui est encore
plus à l'extrême droite de matteo
salvini qui s'appelle giorgia meloni qui
avec son parti fera t-elle lesdites agne
est monté en flèche dans les sondages
est aujourd'hui apparemment c'est le
premier parti en italie je vous rappelle
que nous en italie on va voir les
élections dans un petit peu moins d'un
an mais voilà tout ça pour vous dire le
revirement aussi de d'un allié de
de marine le pen matteo salvini qui est
aujourd'hui c'est paradoxal mais pour
expliquer un français c'est comme si le
pen gouverner dans une majorité d'union
nationale aux côtés d' emmanuel macron
justement parce qu'il ya des menaces qui
nous viennent de l'extérieur et c'est un
moment tellement grave pour notre
histoire et pour notre existence même
que tout le monde doit faire bloc et on
y reviendra parce qu'on va parler
d'europe et c'est effectivement on voit
où on voit que le changement de pied
c'est en miroir par rapport à là où
positionnement de marine le pen c'est
vraiment intéressant de voir ce que
matteo salvini fait depuis deux mois
alain navarro pedro cette admiration de
marine le pen pour vladimir poutine ça
n'a pas empêché plus de 8 millions cent
trente mille français de voter pour l
eau au premier tour comment vous
l'analysez ça il y en aura beaucoup plus
au second c'est évidemment d'avant
moi qui aime danser toute façon rester
dans sa façon de s'en libérer elle a été
la porte et moins d'attention par
exemple qu'eric zemmour ne l'a fait à
l'époque et elle n'a pas et n'a pas
brillé mais bon oui bon c'est comme ça
quoi grosso modo c'était ça en disant
oui c'est pas bien une invasion mais
elle n'a pas permis n a pas donné un
angle n'a pas et ne s'est pas défendu
vraiment et du coup ça a glissé sur
helpe et je ne pense pas que ceux qui
votent marine le pen dans la france
profonde et une grande conscience des
grands enjeux internationaux de
basculement dont parlait pas au loup un
instant et c'est un peu la faute à cette
campagne électorale on en parle je
dirais pas ça je pense qu'ils en ont ils
en ont conscience mais sous l'angle
comme comme nous tous longue du pouvoir
d'achat
quand c'est ça reste une passion
première des français et c'est le
premier impact de ce à dire on y voit la
super bien mais ils étaient bien
conscients aussi qu'il y avait déjà une
inflation avant et
les questions internationales
ce que bon est-ce que les gens disent
pas c'est la faute à poutine donc c'est
la faute à marine le pen je ne pense pas
qu'on fasse cette maison donc elle a
réussi peut-être en étant très low
profile fait profil bas parce qu'elle ne
peut ne savait pas comment faire
autrement je n'en sais rien parce que le
lui a conseillé et la réussit finalement
à se sortir de cette nasse cela et je ne
pense pas et la douce et ça c'était très
intéressant qu'elle précise ses opinions
sur l'otan sur les relations
internationales sur l'europe mais je ne
pense pas que ça va avoir un poids en
france dans le grande majorité des
rectorats hors classe moyenne supérieure
et urbaine que ça aura un contact yves
le bot ouais mais l'image est là au
portugal ne pèse pas papa très bonne
pile est venu défendre un parti
populiste naissant qui tout d'un coup
émergea avec un poids assez significatif
et on n'a pas apprécié on n'aime pas
trop qu'on vient de nous dire comment
faire chez nous et on va se lâcher les
autres comment faire nous plaidons quel
bon c'est toujours assez merci de la
question m'a dit aussi intéressant de
voir le poids de l'extrême droite dans
les différents pays d'europe et je vais
poser la question tout de suite un film
sur sarre présent quand vous regardez
depuis la grande bretagne un parti
d'extrême droite à 23% au premier tour
et potentiellement à 50 et plus au
second on verra bien ce qui se passe
dimanche prochain comment vous réagissez
et que représente l'extrême droite dans
votre pays alors on a toujours un peu de
mal à comprendre pourquoi la france et
seulement attirer entre allemagne mâcon
d'à côté marine le pen de l'autre est
ailleurs depuis 2002 avec l'élection
deuxième tour de jean-marie le pen
et on a du mal à comprendre comment
c'est possible en france aujourd'hui que
la famille le pen arrive toujours à
obtenez doit aussi bon secours est ce
que c'est une malaise qu'on sait c'est
ce qu'a la france et emma dans sa peau
les français centre très nostalgique il
ya du nouveau cette saison vides
d'autres nouvelles pour nos d'autrefois
mais ce que cette bonne heure existait
vraiment et beaucoup de questions qu'on
pose et on a du mal à trouver les
réponses mais là il ya une chose qui est
assez intéressante que on observait
depuis un certain temps parce que vous
savez bien que la compression qui a
quitté l'union européenne depuis un peu
plus d'un an maintenant et boris johnson
a retrouvé une santé avec la guerre en
ukraine alors qu'au début quand tu mènes
le mac ont commencé à parler avec l'un
de mes plus une postion souhaite
retrouver un petit peu marginalisé parce
que avec le break site avec le portugais
a étalé les amendes qu'il a reçues pour
les fêtes 10 dans les semi pros non de
confinement vallée mais plus tu es ne
prenez pas au sérieux donc avec une
question de négocier directement et a
admis à poutine maintenant il a repris
un peu là poil de la bête en disons que
langon bretagne et ton indépendant de
l'europe et est on membre permanent
comme la france du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies est dans une position
maintenant de prendre des décisions
indépendamment des autres pour porter
de l'aide à l'ukraine et d'ailleurs il
ya moins d'une heure boris johnson a
fait une adresse devant les
parlementaires pour s'excuser en quoi
une fois pour les fêtes au 10 downing
street et l'une des questions qui
étaient posées c'était précisément cette
question alors que maintenant vous avez
pris le contact avec vos domaines ce qui
est ce que la grande bretagne peut être
le meilleur du monde le pays qui mène la
bataille contre la russie
indépendamment les eaux parce que vous
n'êtes plus dans l'union européenne donc
quelque part ça servait à bord et
situation de quitter l'union européenne
et donc le bric c'est évident alors très
vite l'extrême droite en bretagne ça
pèse quoi alors l'extrême droite il ya
des similitudes entre
la politique de gestion de ceux
notamment l'attitude vers l'europe mais
ce qu'on n'a pas nous c'est cette
politique anti-immigration
maintenant de nouvelles mesures qui sont
en cours de négociation devra envoyer
tous les migrants qui viennent en
voisins il est pour les bateaux depuis
calais au rwanda mais je pense que c'est
une mesure qui passera pas parce que il
y aura des
des discutent des disputes des disputes
des discussions qui auront lieu dans
l'ensemble des communes mais c'est une
proposition du cubain de monde entre eu
de plus en plus une politique d'extrême
droite mais sans nom alors qu'en france
on a le nom en c2 croyez cgi quand en
anglais c'était pas plus caché dans la
politique générale de l'événement
rhissa vers l'île à la france contre
elle même c'est le titre de votre livre
vous la décrivez dans dans cet ouvrage
vous l'avez retrouvé dans les urnes
dernier oui absolument c'est une france
à celle que vous aviez suivi l'ancienne
ligne de démarcation choisi de suivre
l'ancienne ligne de démarcation
c'est donc cette france très rurale il
faut bien le dire dans laquelle je me
suis plongée c'est le socle de la france
sept flosse france centrale oui je la
trouvais d'ailleurs jeu elle a voté dans
tous ses départements
largement pour marine le pen parce que
c'est une france qui se sont dépossédés
et qui par ailleurs est confronté à tous
les problèmes que l'on connaît pouvoir
d'achat services publics qui sont de
plus en plus disons problématique où il
est plus en plus difficile l'accès des
déserts médicaux donc oui je les
retrouvais moi ce qui me frappe un jeu
je serai un petit peu j'aurais un point
de vue un petit peu différent de celui
d'un mariage d'ailleurs que sûr c'est
pas très étonnant que la question
internationale n'est pas une influence
au premier tour parce qu'au premier tour
les gens se sont positionnés avant tout
d'abord pour en fonction du candidat qui
leur plaisait du programme qui leur
plaisait je soupçonne que ça aura quand
même beaucoup plus importante au second
tour parce que derrière la question
internationale vous avez deux manières
de le traduire il y à la lecture du
conflit la lecture de vladimir poutine
qui est-il peut-on parler avec lui mais
il ya une autre chose c'est chez nous
allons élire les français vont élire le
chef de l'état qui aura éventuellement
besoin peut-être un jour on active et la
dissuasion nucléaire bref il va falloir
d'élire un chef des armées dans une
situation de guerre et cet aspect là
chef des armées en situation de guerre à
mon avis va quand même quelques pas être
beaucoup plus présents les urnes au
deuxième taux qui ne l'a été au 1er mai
c'est la question de la présidentialité
de marine le pen
il ya aussi pour rebondir un brin
questionnement par rapport aux sanctions
c'est à dire que jusqu'ici l'europe agit
en bloc uni en l'approuvant des des
sanctions même même dur et difficile à
l'encontre de la russie de poutine
marine le pen n'a pendant toute sa
campagne n'a pas caché son hostilité par
rapport à ce système de sanction est
donc on se demande si un pays si
important dans l'europe comme la france
va avoir une dame opposés à ces
sanctions à sa tête ça va remettre en
question tout et ça va être une grande
victoire pour poutine je pense aussi
alors justement l'europe écouter ce
qu'en dit bruno le maire le ministre
l'économie c'était ce matin sur europe 1
il dit c'est l'avenir de l'europe de son
centre de gravité qui se joue avec cette
présidentielle on les écoute elle
propose aussi en matière de relations
internationales je le rappelle de couper
les ponts avec l'allemagne de renoncer à
ce qui a fait la prospérité et la paix
en europe depuis un demi siècle
c'est-à-dire l'amitié entre la france et
l'allemagne c'est tout simplement une
folie c'est le reniement de 50 années
d'histoire de la france et c'est en
termes économiques une aberration
complète ce qui nous a permis de
préserver la paix et depuis maintenant
plus d'un demi siècle sur le territoire
européen c'est le fait que deux anciens
ennemis la france et l'allemagne ont
décidé d'avancer main dans la main quand
on veut être président de la république
on est dépositaire d'un héritage
l'héritage de l'histoire de france
depuis 1945 c'est ainsi qu'à vous le
général de gaulle ans evra avec
hors-la-loi ne remet tait oui je
le pense sincèrement
pour les déclarations de bruno le maire
ce matin à navarro pedro
s'est clairement deux visions de
l'europe qui s'oppose là dans cette
campagne française il ya créé 102 aussi
dans les attaques mais alors qu'il
argumente bruno le maire qui nous
explique sur quoi il se base pour pour
aller si loin dans l'analyse c'est clair
et à sa tête et c'est clair
c'est clair que il y aura un coup
d'arrêt à tout ce qui se fait en europe
en ce moment mais est ce la fin est ce
la mort sauf si on est très fragile mais
vous savez pourquoi baisser les bras
même si ma psy pas à marine le pen
venait à être élu pourquoi baisser les
bras en europe même si la situation est
difficile et compliqué c'est napoléon
qui disait la seule bataille perdue
d'avancé celle qui n'est pas livré alors
livrons la cette bataille si jamais
c'est le cas mais elle ne baissons pas
les bras
la rhétorique de la perle et récent dos
tout sera détruit et ça fait partie de
la campagne électorale c'est de bonne
guerre c'est sûr mais à force est
exagéré est ce qu'on ne va pas finir par
anesthésier les peurs et
les réticences alors dans cette danse
marleau et n'ont aucune exagération 16
noms se passe
mais ne pas soutenir un forcément bruno
le maire mais regardons les choses
concrètes en juillet 2020 il ya quelque
chose de très important qui s'est
produit en europe c'est à dire
l'union européenne à grâce aussi au
travail acharné de la france à adopter
quelque chose de très important qui
s'appelle le plan de relance européen
c'est quelque chose qui nous a permis
avec 750 milliards d'euros mis sur la
table pour la première fois de
quelques pas repartir après
la crise sanitaire et tous ces aléas
économiques ce plan de relance n'est pas
un truc il est là et il a été fait grâce
à la france et à l'allemagne c'est clair
que si marine le pen veut se poser à une
politique franco allemande qui a été le
moteur de l'europe depuis l'après-guerre
jusqu'ici une telle ou telle issue un
tel résultat aux lorrains de tels
instruments l'aurait pas donc c'est très
concret tout cela est donc le risque est
qu'une victoire de marine le pen puisse
remettre en cause le processus
d'intégration européenne qu'on est en
train de vivre en ce moment et ça serait
vraiment se tirer une grosse balle dans
le pied un moment de l'histoire où
d'autres super puissances comme la chine
ou la russie ne nous diviser à tout prix
ça serait vraiment bien de notre part et
charlie julien termine loin ce qui me
frappe c'est le discours de marine le
pen qui est au fond est presque
belliqueux sur l'allemagne il faut bien
le dire on a un rôle extrêmement dur moi
j'avais eu l'occasion de la table dans
le dédain auparavant et c'est pas
nouveau chez elle elle a dit qu'elle
veut régler des comptes avec l'allemagne
parce qu'elle estime que l'allemagne de
la france ça c'est sa vision donc déjà
ça c'est très dur mais la vraie question
c'est une fois qu'elle va arriver à
bruxelles elle va faire quoi parce
qu'elle n'arrête pas de dire je vais
faire je vais obtenir les partenaires
mais que je sache les partenaires
européens sont 26 plus la france 27 elle
explique qu'elle aura monsieur urban
monsieur orban croyez moi il a toujours
très bien su ménager les intérêts de la
hongrie et dire une chose à bruxelles et
dire une autre chose à budapest et quant
aux polonais dont on pourrait penser
qu'ils sont les alliés naturels mal
ce sont des atlantistes fini ils sont
complètement pro-américain donc avec qui
va-t-elle faire une coalition parce que
si on s'attaque à l'allemagne imaginons
faisant un peu de politique fiction si
on s'attache faut avoir des soutiens
derrière voir des soupirs derrière alors
là là la vraie question c'est celle ci
alors est ce que l'union européenne
résistent à la perspective je ne sais
pas en tout cas elle réclame de l'argent
à marine le pen via l'office européen de
lutte antifraude cent trente sept mille
euros que la candidate est reine aurait
détourné quand elle était au parlement
européen
son père jean marie le pen son ancien
compagnon louis aliot et bruno gollnisch
sont également accusés au total ça fait
six ans 17000 euros la candidate est
reine elle parle de coup fourré on
écoute confort et de l'union européenne
quelques jours avant le second tour j'ai
une grande habitude de cela et je pense
que les français ne sont absolument pas
dupe je conteste évidemment absolument
ces accusations dont je n'ai pas eu
connaissance qui est déjà posé un
problème en terme d'état de droit
dont on n'a fourni aucune preuve aucun
élément malgré d'ailleurs les demandes
que j'ai pu faire dans le cours de la
campagne annan en europe et drôle le
timing interroge on peut dire à minima
on peut dire ça
défend peut-être on peut bien le monde
et c'est bien ce que je disais livrer
bataille
oui évidemment que le timing interroge
c'est une forme de défense et peut-être
que cet argument un peu porter préjudice
à la candidate de lui faire perdre
quelques voix si jamais certains
électeurs considèrent que c'est
important une certaine probité dans la
gestion de la chose publique on rappelle
que marine le pen a été plusieurs fois
convoqué devant la justice qu'elle a
refusé plusieurs fois de s'y rendre et
que les biens sont compliquées et à ses
relations avec la justice en tout cas on
pas forcément gêné son parcours
politique jusqu'à présent je voudrais
qu'on parle d'une débat qui qui se
prépare
demain soir là aussi paul levy comment
est-ce qu'un d'équivalent en italie de
deux grands ça rejoint l'action valeur
j'imagine que la réponse est non mais de
grands débats comme ça qui passionne
enfin on verra quels sont les audiences
demain soir mais qui passionne les
italiens oui mais c'est pas comparable à
cet ange du débat en france qui est
vraiment comme finale du coupe du monde
et on a des débats bien sûr on a aussi
comme un comme voie nadene un très très
politique en italie ce n'est un peuple
très très achats passionne beaucoup pour
pour la politique il y a des dans le
mode de scrutin des municipales il ya
des ballottages de deuxième tour entre
les candidats à la mairie de rome où
2000 on est là il ya le niveau
national le gouvernement central non et
c'est pour ça que tous les yeux
aujourd'hui sont rivés sur la france
parce que le scrutin français aura un
impact direct sur la vie de nous tous en
italie en grèce en allemagne en espagne
c'est vraiment un enjeu et un vote
crucial pour l'avenir de l'union
européenne est-ce que paolo levi avec sa
passion européenne ne surestime pas un
petit peu le
ce coup de projecteur porté par les
électeurs des autres pays sur notre
scrutin français et est-ce qu'on
portugal on se passionne autant pour
leurs autant de l'état difficilement
mais on se passionne évidemment on est
inquiet parce que ce le portugal c'est
un des petits pays de l'union européenne
est donc assez dépendant
de l'europe pour un certain nombre de la
sphère publique même pour des
financements etc nous sommes tous dans
une grande phase de financement d'un
grand relance d'une grande relance de
l'économie européenne donc la france un
plus n'oublions pas
vous savez la diplomatie portugaise
n'est pas trop mauvaise paraît-il et on
a l'habitude de
faire tomber dans le réel les gens qui
gouvernent un moment donné on est
confronté au réel contenu aux affaires
soit on entre dans une sorte de l'utopie
et là quelque chose du domaine plutôt
explicable par les spécialistes
psychologues mais sinon on retombe dans
le réel dans la gestion des affaires y
aura bien des visiteurs du soir ce du
medef de les acteurs peu économie qui
aura l'europe aussi il y aura les
dépressions et puis parfois papa très
forte nous livrer bataille pas sympa
parce parfois par quelque chose de rond
d'agréables social vous voyez donc
non on pense qu'on aura des temps très
trouble devant nous si marine le pen
élue on ne pense pas que ce sera
beaucoup plus facile c'est une réduction
des manuels mâcon pas pour l'europe
évidemment
mais on pense aussi que les choses ne
seront pas c'est pas la fin des temps il
ya une grande communauté portugaise en
france issu de l'immigration est ce que
il ya un vote homogène où est-ce que il
ya un vote très fort pour le parti de
marine le pen est déjà peu de gens
votent dans cette communauté mais on a
constaté un vent assez fort alors il ya
une thématique centrée conservateur et
cette communauté est venue en france il
ya trois ou quatre générations
lors de la dictature mêlée venu pour des
raisons économiques parce qu'il ya une
dictature ne permettait à personne de
manger à sa faim si on n'était pas bien
né et je ne sais pas il ya quelque chose
qui se retrouvent lundi à l'envi de
l'ordre de 2
oui
nous ne soyons pas caricaturaux alors je
reprends la main parce que pour conclure
il nous reste 5 6 minutes ce sera
forcément l'une des thématiques du débat
demain à question la querelle autour de
la place du voile islamique dans
l'espace public marine le pen veut-elle
vraiment l'interdire il ya eu un peu de
changement de pied le maire de perpignan
louis aliot est le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriel attal se
répondaient ce matin par médias
interposés écouter les calmes curieux
que partout dans le monde les femmes se
battent pour précisément ne pas le
porter par exemple comme en algérie à
quelques années où il ya eu un mouvement
massif de femmes pour ne pas le porter
en raison de la pression sociale et que
nous sommes obligés de se défendre parce
que nous avons cette mesure dans le
programme oui c'est sa capacité à la wii
c'est aussi aujourd'hui la marque de
l'avancée d'un signe politico religieux
dans beaucoup de quartiers et dans
beaucoup de villes ce sera un débat
parlementaire ça fera l'objet d'une
discussion
et puis ce sera mis en application au
fur à mesure mais c'est pas du jour au
lendemain on va les verbaliser les
femmes qui portent le voile parce qu a
pas de loi sur la question photo mh
bâtir une loi et le débat aurait dû
interdire le port du voile par tous sur
l'espace public ça veut dire très
concrètement qu on considère qu elle
considère que la priorité pour nos
policiers c'est d'aller pour chasser les
femmes qui portent le voile pour les
verbaliser moi je pense que nos
policiers sont plus utiles pour la
sécurité immédiate des français pour
aller traquer les délinquants les
trafiquants de drogue et pour lutter
contre l'insécurité dont sont vite
français et alors ça m'intéresse de
savoir ce que vous en pensez philip earl
comment la laïcité à la française et ce
débat est perçu dans notre pays déjà je
pense que le débat sur le port du voile
est un non débat en grande-bretagne truc
c'était assez assez nul un point est
honnête parce que ça va être carrément
impossible d'empêcher les les fans
portaient le voile si elle le désirait
faut dire aussi qu'avec une femme qui
souhaite porter le voile donc c'est pas
parce qu'elles sont obligées de le faire
ça c'est encore une mesure de marine le
pen pour essayer de
se faire élire qu'elle trouve difficile
à appliquer donc elle rétropédale pour
ces deuxièmes parties de l'élection
présidentielle et c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit tout alors qu'elle est en train de
perdre la main ce deuxième tour parce
que elle elle elle est en train de de
fait demi-tour sans plusieurs de ces
mesures donc en grande bretagne
autrefois on encourager les gens à
manifester leur différence de porter le
wild de vivre dans leur commune et y est
mais tout ça a changé à partir des
attentats de 2005 2006 ou à la
britannique se sont rendus compte que
c'était viennent par la bonne politique
à mener mais aujourd'hui il ya une
grande liberté en grande bretagne pour
porter les signes qu'on veut c'est pas
du tout la même chose quand tout en
france richard vers 17 laïcité à la
française elle étonne dans pas mal de
pays du monde oui à layton y compris
dans un pays comme la suisse et
notamment dans sa partie francophone qui
est extrêmement proche de la france nous
on n'a pas du tout cette même approche
et je parle d'un pays la suisse où vous
le savez par référendum il a été décidé
d'interdire la construction des minarets
donc il ya eu une votation populaire qui
l'a interdite mais les femmes peuvent
porter le voile dans l'espace public
dans la rue donc et ça ne choque
personne et d'ailleurs si vous allez cet
été sur les rives du lac léman à genève
vous serez surpris du nombre de femmes
qui portent le voile voir qu'ils sont
complètement vêtue de noir mais il est
vrai qu'en général ce sont des
saoudiennes plutôt fait
on peut retrouver autour du lac
effectivement pas le levi's ce débat sur
le voile
la ccc clairement intéressant ce que ce
changement de pied de marine le pen
depuis depuis 24 ou 48 heures comment
voulez mais lisez écoutez oui elle
cherche de revenir un petit peu sur son
terrain classique elle se pose aussi en
termes de gardienne de la laïcité alors
que la laïcité est une valeur
républicaine et donc qui devrait être
trans partisane et se dit l'éternel
retour d'un débat - effet de 12 ans
maintenant celui-ci en france et avant
je lisais tout le temps les journaux
français parce que j'adore votre pays et
c'est un débat vraiment qui revient
cycliquement à chaque campagne il ya
toujours le voile moi je n'arrive même
plus à vendre mes papiers aux journaux
italiens tellement c'est devenu banal il
sait c'est toujours le même débat c'est
toujours le la laïcité à la française
qui est une une laïcité est un peu
militante qui risque parfois de devenir
elle-même une religion tellement elle
est radicale par moment et que nous
comme l'a rappelé richard
o ou films sont philippe depuis londres
nous avons une autre approche soit la
plus libre bon c'est intéressant d'avoir
ce sur le guerrier allait il nous reste
une minute mathieu je me tourne vers
vous parce que l'une des infos de cette
fin d'après midi
c'est ce sont les déclarations de jean
luc mélenchon sur bfm tv
l'une de ses déclarations je demande aux
français de m'élire premier ministre aux
législatives
oui mais ce raisonnement est il dit
quand même hein je ne veux pas que
madame le pen prennent le pays oui je ne
veux pas que ma qu'on garde le pouvoir
donc je demande aux français de m'élire
premier ministre il vise le 3e tour mais
c'est quasiment une consigne de vote
quand même parce que je ne veux pas que
madame le pen prennent le pays je ne
veux pas que ma manière de pouvoir lui 2
qui serait le premier ministre jean luc
mélenchon si jamais il a remporté une
majorité aux législatives probablement
plus de la première option dans son dans
une vision emmanuel macron évidemment on
l'a bien compris merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir à ce débat initié et en
duplex je rappelle le titre de votre
livre publié aux éditions grasset
richard werly la france contre elle même